hi guys in this video we're going to
give you my best tip for autoimmune
conditions okay now let's talk about
what an autoimmune condition really is
it's a situation where your body is
making antibodies against itself it's
part of the it's like the immune system
is making a huge mistake it's attacking
the wrong thing so instead of stacking
the microbes because that's the purpose
of the immune system to protect you
against microbial infections it decided
to attack itself so you can have
autoimmune conditions - pretty much
anything hormones receptors of hormones
glands body tissue there's over a
hundred autoimmune diseases like for
example Addison's is a adrenal it's a
very low adrenal condition where you're
you have anybody's against your own
adrenal and this that's of the brain
ankylosing spondylitis that's antibodies
against your ligament lupus against
connective tissue Hashimoto's against
the thyroid rheumatoid arthritis
antibodies that are attacking your own
joints in destroying that celiac it's
antibodies against your intestine so you
have this constant inflammatory
condition going on your body where the
organ or tissue can't heal it's usually
triggered by a stress event in fact not
usually if it's always triggered by a
stress event if you talk to someone with
autoimmune and you ask them when did it
start and what happened just before
there will always be either a physical
stress or mainly emotional stress like a
loss BAM they just start getting this
condition so it's the immune system that
has gone bad now what the treatment
usually is steroids like prednisone what
is a steroid it's an adrenal hormone so
the actual cause of autoimmune has to be
some dysfunction of the adrenal gland
itself and so what what can you do about
this doctor royally back in the 30s and
40s and 50s discovered a very unique
strategy for autoimmune conditions and
that is this he found if you took
let's see for example you have Addison's
and you had antibodies against your own
adrenal if you took glandular adrenals
from another species let's say a cow or
a goat or something and you took this
glandular into your stomach and when
it's your stomach your antibodies that
were attacking the adrenal gland would
go what's this and start attacking the
fake or they decoy in the stomach
leaving the adrenal glands alone for a
little while
so it gives the adrenals a break to stop
the inflammation so it's a great
strategy to redirect these antibodies to
a decoy to allow the organ to heal
because there's going to be less
inflammation and then over time if you
kept doing this so over time you can
deplete these antibodies to the point
where the inflammation will go away and
you no longer have any antibodies that
are attacking itself okay there's two
main points I want to bring up if you
take too much of a similar substance you
can create an immune reaction and
sometimes people think that's a detox
reaction when really is just causing
high levels of histamines this demeans
create inflammation they like the teat
poisons so if you take too much you
might wake up feeling a little swollen a
little groggy a little tired like you
have the flu that's because it's just
creating more of a reaction so my
recommendation is to take very small
amount of the substance overall long
period of time and take it before I go
to sleep so that way when you go to
sleep you if it makes you a little bit
more tired you won't notice because
you're sleeping okay so now where are
you going to get adrenal extract brain
ligament connective tissue etc well
standard process is a good company I
don't self in a process you can find a
practitioner or probably go online and
find a standard process product if you
look at all the products they have
certain products that have certain
glandulars in them and they're very
clean you can also you know buy organ
meats you could like you can buy liver
if you have autumn
in your liver you can buy some liver you
can get thyroid extract in certain
supplements you can get adrenal extract
in certain supplements you can get what
about joint in a previous video that I
did on knee pain I talked about chicken
cartilage right well what do you think
you're doing you're taking that the body
is being distracted you're depleting
your antibodies and all sudden your
knees feel better well so it's really
not the cartilage it's just that you're
throwing actual chicken cartilage into
the stomach and it's reaping redirected
over here so let's take celiac for
example if your intestines were you
going to get that well when you buy
sausage a lot of times the lining is
intestines chitlins if we have a little
bit of that they sell sell that at the
store what will happen you can deplete
your antibodies from that as well so
number one you want to get an antibody
test to find out what tissue is involved
in autoimmune then take a small amount
of that tissue either in a pill form or
an actual food small amount over a long
period of time and see if it can help
you alright thanks for watching hi guys
hey listen I created a pretty amazing
evaluation quiz down below that actually
analyzes your symptoms to find the cause
the root cause of all of your symptoms
the most likely cause
so take the quiz now and we'll send you
a report